Hi, I'm Chris Pryby.
I'm a course developer with Udacity and
also former Georgia Tech
graduate student.
I'll be presenting this course on linear
algebra designed specifically for
students of the OMS CS program.
Since linear algebra is
the backbone of many techniques and
algorithms in computer science, we
wanted to provide a resource for OMS CS
students to learn or brush up on some
of the fundamentals of this subject.
But instead of giving just another set
of lectures on this topic, we wanted to
put linear algebra in the context of
how you will use it in this program.
In this course,
in addition to learning some theory,
you will be implementing
the algorithms we discuss yourself.
By the end you will have built your own
library of linear algebra functions.
The only necessary background for
this course is knowledge
of a programming language.
But some familiarity with
elementary algebra and
trigonometry will be helpful as well.
I'm looking forward to this course and
I hope you are too.
Let's go ahead and get started.